Ann: Barnett Newman's
paintings are those which among
the abstract expressionists
themselves caused
the greatest amount of
skepticism and doubt.
Newman epitomized the common sense
of many abstract expressionists
painters works that anybody can do that.
I think Newman's paintings pushed
that to its furthest extreme.
Not so much in that they looked
like something a child could do,
because it's pretty hard to
make those straight lines,
but something that a house-painter
could do and in fact one of the critics
of one of his early shows
at the Betty Parsons Gallery
wrote that when you went
into the gallery, you thought
you were looking at the wall
but then you realized oh no,
you were looking at the paintings.
So our question is, what really
does separate these paintings?
Well for one thing, the layers
of color on a Newman painting
are not the one or two that
a house-painter might make
but in fact countless layers to
achieve the saturation and the subtlety
of tone that Newman was looking
for in the surface of his painting.
Also he's not dealing
with a predetermined area,
for the feeling of a Newman
that's smaller than you
as opposed to one that occupies
the whole length of a room,
communicate very different feelings.
So of all the decisions
that Newman is making
to get the effect that we see today,
none of them is actually that simple.
Instead what Newman is doing is
trying to communicate a mood,
a profound feeling, one might
call it a spiritual feeling.
At that time he would have, today that
would be quite unfashionable to use.
But there's no doubt in my mind that
for Newman, what he was expressing
in a rather secular medium,
painting, was the kind of thing
that in previous times would
have been called religious.
The idea behind a Newman painting
is not that you look at it
and understand it or get it.
I think that's one of the things
that has bothered people about Newman
ever since these paintings
first were shown 60 years ago.
With a Newman you have to set
aside all expectations of that
and surrender yourself to
the physical experience
and the psychic experience of
being in the space of this picture.
In fact if you look through New Yorker
magazines of the 1950's and 1960's,
you'll find many many
cartoons filling its pages
of perplexed viewers standing in front
of abstract expressionist paintings,
probably right here at
the Museum of Modern Art.
But instead really what they're trying
to convey is that it wasn't easy
for them as painters to make
the art that they were making,
nor should it be easy for the
viewers to experience what they made.
For all of these artists it was essential
that they form a signature style
and much as Pollock is somebody
we associate with his drips,
Newman is somebody we associate
with what we now call his zips.
This was something new in modern
art and yet at the same time
as they were concerned with
making Rothko's or Newman's,
with these very clearly
identifiable styles,
at the same time they maintained that
these pictures were not about them,
that they were not about their mood
or their story they wanted to tell,
certainly not about any biographical
detail and instead they were about
the much larger issues of
values and ideals of humankind.
This is something that should
take you above your daily routine.
Out of your ordinary work, out
of your ordinary family life.
When you're with these paintings
you're going somewhere else
and you're bringing your soul,
you're bringing your brain,
you're bringing your physical
body into a different realm.